[Music]
this guy is
getting ready to
go talk to some friends of ours we heard
that uthman's in town
with another special guest
so we're gonna see if we can get a
conversation
all right
you know it's always good to say hi you
know I was getting ready to go
stream
with David wood
but I don't know if I could pass this up
right now the stream will be there when
I get back
the idea yeah hey what's up man how are
you doing all right
you know I couldn't miss this man
beautiful
that where I open this account for the
property
[Music]
and again I have a video you can look at
this guy you can watch that no problem
well I know my friends
you got to hold it that's why you just
gotta hold it
yeah look again like I said talk to you
guys move on move on just away from you
we appreciate it thank you I think I
want to have a conversation with mine
okay
we're over here in peace but not
disturbing on you can continue his
conversation you're disturbing us I'm
not saying anything you can have this
conversation I'm chilling so anyway we
got rudely interrupted there
notice notice it wasn't us that did the
interruption we was chilling
[Music]
follow me
to come here and I mean don't go through
classes
nothing's about cloud my man we just uh
yeah no you're in front of me so I'm
going to pushing me no no don't get in
front of me don't get in front of me I
appreciate if you don't touch me yeah I
did all right good all right
talk to you guys
but you're just not out here getting
views and trying to disrupt them
look we how about that one actually I
actually had a question look hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
I had a question
hold on hold on I'm listening go ahead
talk to me
look we're out here we're giving our
dawa we've had raise it high there you
go raise it up you're listening but
you're just trying to get down
I'm listening
nobody's afraid I've already talked to
you look look I've talked to both of you
yeah we've got videos yeah you don't
even let me read the verse from the
Bible last time
let me finish let me finish okay you
didn't even me read how would you know
what verse I'm talking about you're
talking about I know I'm talking about
the Quran
look look I I told you last video it's
online you didn't even let me read a
single verse all right
because you were rude because look you
were rude and the videos aren't like
yeah as well you and about your wife
beating and all that stuff we've already
talked to you about it we've talked to
you about it survival contradictions
all right let me finish you promised to
listen to I'm not here to talk to you
today okay so you just want you just but
if you if you only want to explain I'm
willing to listen Okay but I wanna I
wanna I wanna say something but this is
a discussion then right so I'm here okay
good you have you have here's the next
question we could both tell you you have
your table and you go to your table go
to your table but you're you're here
doing now so so we're having you're here
to have a conversation
we're here to talk to you not yeah I'll
tell you why you're gonna talk to you
I'll tell you why you're not why because
you came before the videos are on our
Channel yeah
even the Christian Anthony that was with
you guys there even he admitted it's all
on video it's all on video yeah that you
guys didn't let me but you know you lied
about the coronation of course I did not
lie about it so then why didn't you
translate all online why didn't you
translate it all online people can look
up the verses why don't you translate it
only
tonight
I have a question about the comforter
okay let me read that let me I have a
question I have a question about the the
comforter Kryptonite I have a question
about the comforter
okay go ahead
can you can you get out the way further
I appreciate you touching me again I'll
call somebody no you can call anybody
you want he's he's a grown man he can
talk to me don't touch me second king
can you excuse me all right what's up
with you bro hold on hold on hold on
this guy can you can you step aside all
right thank you I was 22 years old when
he became king look at this no but he's
disturbing me or he's talking to me I'm
talking to you but he's over here
you have somebody over there that's
touching my stuff
he'll listen to you listen well actually
it's the slavery in Islam actually no
it's not okay yeah so can y'all can
y'all can y'all chill out man what y'all
afraid are we chilling man come on let's
have a conversation so many times
old when he became king and he reigned
one year in Jerusalem yeah and then you
know in in the same Bible you have them
at 42. huh what's up with the different
agents uh well the different agents are
talking about him ruling at two
different times
no you're not ruling at different times
you you bring it up you bringing up some
type of commentary or whatever it
doesn't mean anything okay
are you talking to me
okay cool because I already answered
this because someone else brought this
up you guys can all check out godlogic
apologetics go ahead and check out the
channel you guys can see you guys can
see the answer when we was debunking
Islam and debunking a Muslim who brought
up this objection and I answered it so I
posted the verses earlier
the ruling of Isaiah happened twice he
ruled once when he was 22 got kidnapped
by the uh by the uh by the Arabians in
the Philistines and then he got freed
and ruled again at 42. it's as simple as
that he only ruled one year twice
because one he was ruling he was a
co-ruler with his father while his
father was in his sick bed that's
co-rulership that's when he began to
rule right the first time when he was 22
then he ruled again when he got when he
uh came back to Jerusalem when the
people picked him as The King and I can
show you the verses all right
this is the book that this man brought
okay this is the hypocrisy that's gonna
get caught live right now this man and
the videos on our Channel and probably
his channel right this man brought this
book card through Study Bible right
about about the Bible yeah no no not the
Bible the McCarthy Study Bible so what
he brought it here to our tent to tell
us this is the authoritative work that
he answered our questions from now you
heard his me using me using an answer
from one understanding doesn't mean
anything you see him interrupt me now no
you you literally interrupted me the
whole time he's interrupting me is he
interrupting you know we heard your
point yeah
now this man and you can go check the
one message Foundation Channel you can
see the video when he came here to
Balboa Park with this exact same book
and he told me the answers for these are
from here and when I questioned him he
told me this is the McCarthy Study Bible
on this I got it and I bought it now you
heard his answer what is the McCarthy
Study Bible say about Isaiah's Reign
does it say they were two different
times no it says this is a copiest error
wow this this is no no look at hypocrisy
he brought this book he brought this
book to us right wait so the explanation
is not that he ruled twice but that is
accomplished read it 42 this is a
copious error easily made to due to the
small Strokes that differentiate two
Hebrews yeah textual variant is what he
said oh so you do know
I I don't I don't know that's the book
he brought now can I respond to this no
go ahead yeah can I respond to this
question let me let me finish let me
finish okay go ahead so I'll answer you
after this sure no no the hypocrisy cut
life is this man brought this book used
this as a reference gave me reference to
answer the contradictions from it and
today when it clearly shows that his
answer is not that of the McCarthy Study
Bible who's definitely better read than
him right now he's gonna run from it
he's gonna jump he's caught on tape in
fact the NIV version I believe and you
can correct me if I'm wrong actually
change the age now what because oh oh oh
because they said this this was an error
so notice how for let me respond to this
because it's all together okay so he's
put he's posing this as if John
MacArthur is my ultimate Authority I
used John MacArthur to answer a certain
question and that doesn't mean that he's
my authority on everything so to be fair
I did bring the star MacArthur Study
Bible I used it in one of the answers
you know a couple actually I actually
used it twice okay but in my
understanding and Fuller understanding
with this particular one I use the Bible
and I use bible verses to answer this
apparent objection so the Bible talks
about how uh ahaziah ruled twice how he
ruled joint with his father right in the
book of Quran Chronicles and how it
talked about how he was kidnapped and
taken and plundered
let me finish let me finish no it's not
a contradiction because it's talking
about him ruling twice if he ruled once
when he was 22 and then he ruled later
on when he was 42 is that a
contradiction
answer is that a contradiction I don't
know because no no no no the Bible
doesn't say it's an error that's
someone's opinion saying it's a textual
variant no I didn't no no let me I asked
Tony because I'm the better no no
problem so if if the answer that I gave
you that in one uh particular context he
rules once when he's 22 and the other
one he rules later when he's 42 is that
a contradiction sure it's but the book
you brought you don't know not agree
with that I don't agree with that that
is a textual variant I don't agree with
that okay that's what I'm saying no no
but you didn't answer you no you didn't
answer my question if if at one point he
ruled that 22 and then later ruled at 42
is that a contradiction before you end
no let him answer please he's a grown
man
let me ask me a question he asked me a
question I mean he asked me a question
let me ask you a question he asked me a
question I thought that they were the
better listeners
listen to you all right so don't touch
me
and what did I say not you said that you
don't agree with it correct and what did
I say my answer is I said that he ruled
twice right yeah okay so I answered your
question and then I'm returning the
question I can't answer your question
properly if we don't even establish it
the book is correct no no if you find a
contradiction then we can no no no it
has nothing to do with whether you
believe if the book is is established or
not my question is very simple if let's
say let's say if we take the book out of
it let's say sneako you how old are you
bro 24 you're 24 okay so let's say when
did you start your YouTube channel 14
14. let's say you let's say um um uh one
one one Tech says that sneakos did a
YouTube video when he was 14. right and
then another tech said sneaker did a
YouTube video when he was 24. is that
contradiction let me ask be quiet please
bro let him answer let him answer is
that a contradiction is that a
contradiction to what so what is that a
contradict does can you do a video at
one point in one year and then do
another video uh in another year is that
a couple I wouldn't say that I saw I
wouldn't say that I started YouTube
twice I'm not saying
I would never write that I did it twice
because I'm still but but you did but
you did do a video twice
listen if you were on YouTube for one
year yeah and then you deleted your
account and then you were on YouTube for
four years how many years were on
YouTube
when he became king and he reigned for
one year in Jerusalem only one year
right now in the same Bible when you go
to the news
we already saw this you literally
interrupted me the whole time
when he was 42 when he ruled but he only
ruled for one year so that means no it
does not take twice he's adding that no
it's the Bible here it's only one one
year in two different ages now ask him
in the NIV version did they change this
or not okay no so no you're gonna know
you're gonna no you're going to deal
with my question
so why did they do that hold on one
second
do you know what a contradiction is yes
Define contradiction two things that
cannot be true at the same time
beautiful so thank you now answer this
question for me can it be you see no no
no no no no because we're dealing with
this so-called contradiction don't run
running outside
so okay cool so if if somebody's ruling
at 22 okay and they only rule for one
year because an invasion happens okay
and and so you're saying that it's
impossible for 20 years later for him to
return to the city and then become king
again enroll for one year is that a
contradiction answer do you understand
the question I do okay is that a
contradiction okay I want to hear it if
somebody ruled it you're not answering
the question do you see that it's a yes
or no do you see that it's like yes
and then he came back and ruled another
year I would say he ruled for two years
no that's because gosh are you kidding
unfortunate these guys
and he deleted it and then he started
again I would say he's been on YouTube
for five years because this is the con
the the total amount if somebody ruled
for one year and they were taken out and
they ruled again for a year then you
would say he ruled for two years
beautiful no no I'm gonna show you this
comment in a second why did the NIV
version take that age of 42 out because
they think it's a textual variant that's
why
out when you can't find the clip will
you admit that you lied sure on camera
on your channel on my channel
okay cool
and you prayed and I said NIV yes right
yes and then we find that yeah NIV
change the dates knowing it's a it's an
error
the Bible said as well
we have to leave no no no
I know so can I respond to what you said
let me finish no I did look we already
said so can I respond to what you're
saying because I want to show you the
strawberries no but you yeah thank you
all right here we go here we go hey they
can't they can't move it you're they're
too short they can't see okay so here we
go so look so let me show you the straw
man and what he did listen to the
example the example that he gave is he
said if I said that he was ruling as
king one year and then he ruled uh uh I
mentioned another year that he ruled
then that's in total he ruled
accumulative of that Gap that's what
he's saying yeah I'm saying that no
according to the text his rules stopped
twice he stopped ruling at 22 and then
he ruled again it's not that he ruled
that 22 and then continued until he was
42. no he ruled at 22. let me finish let
me finish he ruled at 22 the Arabians
and the Philistines invaded Jerusalem
kidnapped him for 20 years he was gone
not the king anymore he came back at 42
they made King again and he ruled only
one year that year because he was sinful
to God that's two years no that's two
two years let me finish I listen to you
I'm listening thank you so if you're
trying to say then and all his in all
his life he ruled two years sure no
problem but that's not what the text is
talking about the Texas talking about
specifically when he started to rule at
the particular age that he started to
rule okay so that's the straw man that
you did I hope that you understand when
you look
respectfully beautiful he continued to
respectfully listen so before you bring
a straw man analogy when you bring an
analogy make sure it matches with the
actual uh situation all right so I
answered your question
no no no wait hold on hold on I still
have something to say hold on I'm not
done I'll let you go I'll let you go
which I did that you would answer my
question you guys was wooing and oohing
off of a textual variant that some
people believe so if you believe in
textual variants that disprove the Bible
then you have to explain to us the
textual variance that you still haven't
translated I want you to tell me first
of all in chapter 37 verse 12 who is it
that's surprised is it Muhammad that
surprised or is it Allah who's surprised
chapter 37 verse 12. go ahead I want you
to answer that no no you notice I told
you you're not going to jump no you told
me that once I answer you will change
the subject that's exactly what it is
you promise once I answered you we could
change that's what you said you put
something forward if you don't have my
answer that's on you it's not it's not a
little happy I actually answer the
question it is often but he did say if
you answer this question then I'll
answer yours right did he say that let
me let me finish it's legal did he say
that be honest bro yeah okay thank you
so no so we're gonna see if you lying or
not relax we're chilling we're chilling
no no
first thing is that
this man came out and gave an
explanation that clearly people it's
different Interruption
is he a great listener you
you have nothing to say you have no
Authority keep continue oh easy there
guys
now what I made clear is him trying to
jump from the subject and I told him
he's gonna jump and that's exactly what
he did right we said okay if we find the
clip of him praising an IV and inshallah
we will
admit to being alive don't say inshallah
that never happens I always never comes
to pass that is not true all right no no
once again no just say well
answer that he you don't even know we
don't have a life or something you
should say you say you should say I
swear let's go back let's go back now
what he jumped with is the fact that the
the great he will have to let him finish
that he brought as an authority which
the videos are online disagree with him
in fact in the NIV we will find our
praise but even if you don't the NIV
clearly said oh even if you don't now
you get nervous about it all right so
don't don't try to plug that in you see
him in trouble you're going to find it
right
I'm not gonna let him escape from stuff
you know people speaking I know how to
handle them a lot of people don't you
think you do right now when you look at
the variant Christian scholar who
updated the Bible said that this story
is not true they said this was a copious
error in fact and I can prove that
because there are manuscripts you're
paying attention seagull yes there are
manuscripts in Greek that mention 22 on
both yeah that is that is so so it's a
texture now you see you see now
you hear that now now it's not that he
ruled that two ages
we don't have a problem are there
manuscripts and mentioned 22
is are there manuscripts that in in both
verses in the same manuscript mentioned
the same age I don't know that I just
know that in one manuscript it'll say
22. and another manuscript it says right
that's what I know
have you read an IV
um not in this verse oh
have you read the NIV version of the
Bible uh in some verses okay people
people life
pull up the NIV version what's the
problem
I have no problem are you going to
answer the question I am okay cool see
you ran I didn't you got caught now and
that's why you're nervous get caught in
wet you got caught in a lie right what
lie no what lies no load up NIV you said
you pull up you said a manuscript pull
up an idea but you said a manuscript
Bible
what is it first Kings right they pay
him money first Kings 8 22. you guys do
you no
you're over here
I'm not getting paid to be I choose to
be here okay good me too but are you
getting paid to be here no are you you
have a patreon yeah I do yeah so fake
shot is for what for people who love the
movies
like a single penny off YouTube that's a
lot you do what you you know you make
money
don't change the subjects
do I get paid
again oh why because people because
you're biased people say that oh so so
the fact that I don't get paid bro
you're running look you're running okay
look you're running second life you're
running you're running taxes you're
running to see who they pay can you
define is he a liar could you get to the
subject no no no no no it's not nothing
if I show you on this topic and I don't
get paid is he alive this dude is
hilarious right
he said no problem
no problem tonight
he said I do get paid but I do it
now you're running from that yeah
NIV Bible chapter one okay so what are
you doing so that we all know 22 what
are you proving here
for both
but this is the one in case what's the
point you said you've never read it I
haven't not the NIV this is Kings
it says 22 both times
remember he hasn't read it okay
what's wrong with it now first it went
two years it says
why does NIV
change it to 22 because they believe
it's a textual variant there so they're
going with the other variants
that's Bible there was an error in the
it no they changed it no it's
interrupting yourself
right no no you're not going to answer
the call is NIV shows that that their
research that this was an error but she
said I use the NIV you do use the NIV
you're lying we'll get the video right
now he mentioned here 42 right and he
said because he ruled twice NIV and
McCarthy they all said that this was a
copious error in the Bible and they even
changed it because they said he didn't
rule twice this was a clear error in
fact if you look at the commentaries on
the NIV and and I have some at home that
I can bring for you if you haven't read
them right they say that no doubt this
was a copious error no they don't say
nothing
I'll bring them to you don't wait yeah
right now now what is the study Bible
you brought right
when he brought up a particular question
I used the nib Study Bible to use an
answer that I agreed with because it was
another description which studied by the
ESV study oh he just said an IV I never
said an IV well look he just said an
idea
did you understand
so I used the study Bible because there
was a particular question that he asked
that I agreed with that it was in line
with the scripture right here what this
this textual variant that they're saying
is a copy is here I don't agree with
because there's a scriptural answer
regarding this particular uh so what
book is your Authority the Bible wait do
you know better than to make sure so my
point is so my point is listen no so my
point is he has not been able to refute
the answer about Isaiah ruling at 22 and
then ruling at 42. the only thing that
he's done is well in this Bible it says
this or in this Bible it says this but
he has not been able to answer the
explanation that I gave with the
scripture that's my point so we've dealt
with the explanation that it's an error
no my explanation is that he ruled twice
once at 22 got kidnapped by the
Philistines and Arabian so you disagree
with the book that you brought I
disagree with their explanation
we can leave it at that I said that in
the beginning I think that's why a lot
of people resonate with Islam because we
don't disagree with the scripture oh
we'll see we'll see in a second all
right so no you said
whatever one you use
foreign
Egypt
go ahead what does it say what's the
yard what's the translation
I
all these are recitations
thank you
it color codes
now check this out this is where their
ignorance gets caught oh listen right no
no what is the difference it is
changing hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on this is this is where you're
gonna see him get buried just watch okay
in the must-have that I showed you at
home right in the original mustaf were
there these lines no there were no
diacritical marks so how do you know
which one is finished
I can't remember okay thank you tonight
I'll show it okay
now I'm doing them the same way yeah
yeah okay good so how do you know how to
read it I got you okay now let me finish
go ahead okay no please answer how do
you know how to read it you see that
he's answering I'm listening watch him
not answer okay go ahead 100 I'm
answering just let him be quiet okay now
what the mistake they made is the fact
that the um
he's a better listener yeah let's see
yeah we'll see now is the must-have
the original must-have has no dietary
marks it has no dots and I'll show it to
you tonight again inshallah he's telling
the truth finally all right now when you
have for example
okay now as for example in South Africa
now let me finish he's not gonna finish
right he's not gonna be finished in
South Africa when they ask you how are
you they say how is the brother right
they're talking to you but they say how
is the brother okay now
now watch the nail on the coffee right
put it on in Arabic it's the same way
yeah sometimes they would use with the
second sometime with the fat house
sometimes with dhamma right now find me
an English translation looking at the
meanings from all the Quran that gave a
different meaning
so first of all you just you literally
just tried to throw the Arabic under the
bus and now he's appealing to the
English and say show me an English
translation that shows a difference are
we talking about English or Arabic
answer no answer the questions is it
Arabic or English it's just one word yes
go ahead you're not gonna tell me okay
so all right so you're not gonna answer
there
yeah no I'm just going my turn because
you're not going to answer so yeah let
me continue let me continue yeah let me
continue let me continue now when you
say it in Anthony the meaning is taken
no no hold on hold on
I listen to you
I know you do but you and you don't want
to hear the response you see that so he
spoke can't respond if he doesn't know
but he spoke for a minute he spoke for a
long time and all I did was ask the
simple question and I want someone alone
so yeah respect respectfully answer let
me respond respond after this respond
after okay so because I know you're not
going to answer
so this is what you have you have uthman
the Sheikh who says show me an English
difference not the Arabic forget the
Arabic let me throw the Arabic under the
bus let me see any English translation
that changes it this is hilarious coming
from this most uh clear Quran that's
revealed into Arabic so don't try to
challenge me to show you an English
translation we're dealing with the
Arabic this is the question to you is it
objecta or object two which one is it
because they both change it and if
you're saying that they don't wait till
I show you what our court to be says go
ahead first thing you kept saying ja and
it's not just it's ta it's taught
[Music]
let me think let me finish wait wait
just just I'll let you go just real
quick quick it's just a clarifying
question I'm gonna answer mine it's just
it's just clarify I'm going to answer
the questions
do you acknowledge that one is taught
and the other is two that's the question
go ahead
go ahead answer when he's done go ahead
answer and
so anyway that's right
oh my God
so you got to answer the question okay
no I'm gonna you wanna you wanna spend
most of your time on the Bible and not
the Quran
is it still recording yeah check the
time
I'm sorry
okay now like you said I explained the
English example
so here it's great in the Quran in
Arabic it's used to give the same
meaning and differences same meaning no
hold on look I've read I've got it at
home yeah so what is
let me explain first I said because
there's a difference
no stop lying have you ever read it I
read them in this one
now when you have a different way of
pronouncing and explaining something in
the qurat it will be the scholars of
Islam when they look at the different
whether it was
and its effect on the meaning they took
it together and looking at all the fact
that every manuscript comes from one
Musa
the fact that it did not have harakat
they took the meaning and that's why
they came to a conclusion of the meaning
and translate so answer the question
again
no you're not answering the question
what do you remember the question
yeah what was the question
you're asked the dots no I'm not I'm
not or two does it does one say tall and
the other say two yes or no let me
answer please it's a yes or no
pronounce it different I got you and the
meaning of it you come back to the
prophet salallahu in the end is it the
same as the house is when it says two
here's my question in the hospital you
don't understand in the house research
listen to the question so you're not an
answer no but you need to know the
question I'm going to listen to you
thank you and the hofs it says it's it
ends with TA in the al-kasai and the
Hamza it ends with two correct although
does that have the same meaning yes or
no
are you done with your question that's
my question okay thank you no
once again when you look at Arab in the
Arabic language it changes with the
dietary marks right sure are you paying
attention oh yeah I'm just waiting for
the answer listen I'm listening if you
listen you get the I'm listening okay
now when you use Arabic there are
different dialects that will use first
person second person understood yes
you're right okay now Scholars like
portavi will discuss the Arab of it
right but there are Scholars who
specialize in sure don't pay attention
no I'm waiting for the answer good who
said that
is all going to be from the same
must-have and they're going to bring the
same meaning okay but they can be
pronounced differently okay let me
finish so wait one of the answer but one
is one says you wonder the other says I
wonder once again once again is that
true or not that's what I was trying to
explain is that true or false listen to
the answer I am I'm waiting for it look
true or false one says you wonder the
other says I won once again now listen
answer the question please
in in South Africa as I was giving you
the example oh my God they would ask you
how is the brother now if I say that
here how is the brother am I talking
about you or somebody else
somebody else excellent but in South
Africa and their action when I say how
is the brother they're talking about you
right right see it so pronunciation
difference is very different than get a
whole age you're complaining that
difference to 22 and 40. no I'm not
exactly it's not the same thing as like
different so now here it is so if I say
if I say are you really gonna think
about that let's see let's see if I said
you sat down at the table
and I said I sat down at the table is
that a difference in languages they have
different needs is that a difference
that's different there's a difference
I'm not equating I'm just showing that
there's a difference
okay but hold on we'll see you said that
you all say there's only one Quran no
meaning changes right that's what he
just said he said the meaning goes all
the way back to Muhammad so if the
meaning doesn't change but you just
acknowledge that don't worry it's not a
meaningful way
okay so if that's okay if it's not a
meaning change let's see if I say you
sat at the table versus I sat at the
table is that the same thing in
different languages they mean different
things oh thank you so it doesn't mean
the same thing so I do mean the same
things but in different languages no
it's not if leading that to 26. sneak up
you sitting at the table is different
from me sitting at the table if I said I
saw you uh shooting a basketball and
then I said I saw eyes
different languages no I'm in the same
language the only thing that different
no no listen listen to what he explained
because it looks like nobody else was
listening because I understood what you
said he said he did it watch watch he
said he said that in with certain marks
it changes from first person to third
person and things of this nature right
so the tense changes based on the time
the two or whatever so if it's a time
it's you you wonder right while they
mocked if it's a two it's I wondered why
they mocked that's not the same thing
because the one who's speaking is
talking about somebody else in another
tense when in the other one in that same
in that same verse the tent switches to
the speaker speaking about himself
instead of someone else so the meaning
changes that's my point so if the
meaning changes who is it that's being
surprised is it Muhammad or is it Allah
who's being surprised he says you
wondered why they mocked and the other
one Allah says I wondered why they
mocked which one is it again once again
and you're saying this even though you
don't even know how to read the verse
correctly right you didn't read the risk
correctly I didn't no you didn't I
didn't I'm the one who told you how to
read it I'm the one who told you how to
read it now once again once again I'm
gonna answer this and then we got things
to go right now wait you said you was
going to explain I could to be so what
it could be saying
what they want to do what they want to
do is keep us here as long as possible
just to get views
one more time one more what is our court
to be saying that that object two is
impossible why does he say that's
impossible exactly that's the point why
portobi says it's impossible because the
scholar said that when you have a job
too it would be referring back to Allah
but the Arabic accent does not it is
the Great the great Scholars with
understanding he's burying himself
dialect they said I just burying himself
he's referring to the prophet sallallahu
that's why I told them because every
English translation around the world
that looked at all the translations said
English now he's referring to English
again not the Arabic forget the Arabic
because the Arabic meaning you don't
understand really in English now again
I'm going to give you a third time
because
because you're being loud you gotta got
your moment no we're just talking
sooner or later on you're gonna see
you're gonna see the flaw on what he
just said because you just said that
occur to be said it's impossible because
it it goes back to Allah right so so
there is a difference right what you
don't understand is in the Arabic
language there were times where you
would use second person third person I
understand for somebody else like I give
the example the beginning no I
understand that but you're repeating
that doesn't help because you don't
understand it if we just in the same
language if I said how is the brother
here somebody would say let's refer
somebody else but in South Africa
knowing their language they knew that
it's referring to them so as the Arab
knew I jumped to here is referring to
the prophets
can you show me can you show me anywhere
in our country where he said that
nothing bro
the end all here right but none of the
scholarships I will I will bring you
those Scholars right can you show me
recovery said it where Jenna Lane said
it works
I read them on this subject in what
language and I wrote it in the English
language
but I have Arab experience you
because those Scholars looking at the
variants showed the same meaning and
that's why they literally they literally
said it's not the same meaning all
translated one way that's not true some
of them said okay name one the time
yes
so he's trying to say he's trying to say
that all the scholars say that object
two and objectives that's what you just
said she said so no they don't the
scholars say that one is impossible
while the other is is acceptable because
Allah cannot be surprised that's what
good to be saying that's why they said
this is not the meaning of Allah this is
the meaning of the Prophet that's why
they rejected
they rejected that reading no they
rejected that reading they rejected that
reading have you ever even read it I
read I read you ever read I read this
verse
everybody
we can go yeah let's go but let's
let's shake it again
[Music]